so what was the first catalyst to get
all of these youtubers because you have
more than just two okay you have eight
okay well and what was like the first
catalyst that then got all these other
youtubers on board it was it just word
of mouth through sort of the YouTube
community that you were casting well
once the gradual report here's the thing
the one of the parts in the film for box
office girl which we actually named Nora
was originally written for a youtuber
called coping saw her and she's wanted
to people i wrote the parts for like
with them in mind she was one of them
because my girlfriend were showing me
this makeup tutorials and i saw this
person she was so funny and so talented
and actually I wrote a part I hope we
end up contacting that personal YouTube
somehow at some point and we did she
wanted and she did and she's great so
that's one of the two parts I've written
for the other one was a part of this
person they meet along the way and he
actually is the biggest actor in Serbia
he was actually the lead in the movie
the one pound or 95 underground by
cuscus so you know it's a heavy hitter
he wanted to do it he did but as far as
youtubers I think that's what I started
when I me wanting to cast Gloria courage
I just knew about her from YouTube and
then I guess that whole you know things
I responding when how about some other
guys because they're so talented just
you know if it's it's it's they're all
great do you think a lot of independent
filmmakers and also mainstream
filmmakers realize that the power of the
YouTube fans is there and it seems like
right now YouTube sort of like the
stepchild the redheads
child and you know but I think there is
such a power there there's so much on
youtube there's so much of a following
do you think people are cognizant about
you know I don't know I you know
Hollywood has things in place and I'm
learning that and it takes them a while
to sort of you know unroot and pick up
on where I mean a lot of ways another
things that are very progressive so as
far as casting youtubers IRS the
approach them is really talented actors
extremely time detectors and then I
wonder how come everybody else doesn't
know about them and then you realize it
is good chunk of people do it all by and
they love watching them in but they're
not just actors there are content
creators that's what's so interesting
but it's going new breed of an actor
like they're able to come up with your
whole stuff right it directed put it
online and attract the eyeballs which is
your very different than just hitting
auditions
you